MICHAEL YU: Good
afternoon, everyone.
First off, thanks
for coming today.
I'm really excited to be here.
My name is Michael Yu.
I'm a software developer
on Google Cloud Storage.
And with me today
is James Malone.
He's a product manager
on Google Cloud Dataproc.
So over the last
couple years, I've
had the opportunity to work
with a bunch of our users,
and see some of the
issues that they run into.
So today, what we
were hoping to do
was go over some of the
common issues that we see
and some of the
common misconceptions,
as well as some of
the common solutions.
And we're only going to
touch a handful of these.
There's not enough time to
really cover a lot of them.
But what we're also
hoping to do is
give you a little bit of insight
in terms of how the service is
working, and why we made
certain design decisions that
can lead to certain problems.
So hopefully, this
will be really
interesting and useful and fun.
Here's the agenda for today.
The talks are broken down
into four main sections.
The first two sections
cover our primary use cases,
which are data processing
and content serving.
So for data processing
workloads and content serving,
we're going to first talk
about storage classes.
And the reason why is that
there's some misconceptions
around them.
Particularly,
we've commonly seen
that some folks believe
that multi-regional
is a strictly superior
storage class to regional.
And that's not true.
There's actually
trade-offs between the two.
And so we'll go into some
of the latency differences
and some of the
consistency differences.
We're also going to talk about
roughly what performance you
can expect out of GCS.
And we're going to talk about
how to change your access
patterns to take advantage
of our relative strengths,
and hopefully work around some
of our relative weaknesses.
The third section is going
to be on write scaling.
This is a problem that
we see fairly often.
Folks will end up
hitting a bottleneck.
And they're not able to scale
the number of writes per
second they can get.
So we're going to take a look
at some of the design decisions
that we made that resulted
in this hot spotting.
And we'll sort of
explain our rationale
for making those decisions.
And then we'll of course talk
about ways to get around that.
And then finally, we're going to
wrap up talking about retries.
You know, retries is
probably something everyone's
familiar with.
But there's different
strategies you
want to use when
dealing with errors
versus dealing with slow
requests and tail latency.
So we're going to talk
about a technique called
hedge requests, which is a good
way to deal with tail latency.
OK.
So let's get to the
first section, which
is data processing workloads.
Hopefully, you guys are all
familiar with storage classes
for GCS.
But let me give a quick
overview for those who aren't.
So we have four main
classes, multi-regional,
regional, nearline and coldline.
For the multi-regional storage
class, what we guarantee
is that you're going to
have at least two replicas.
And they're going
to be geo diverse.
So the replicas are
going to be located
at least 100 miles apart.
So in this particular
example, we have four objects.
There's a replica for each
of them in the left region.
And then the second replicas
for the other four objects
are split between the
middle and the right region.
The second source
class is regional.
And here you select a
very specific region
to store your data.
And we guarantee
that all of your data
lies within that region.
The last two source classes
are nearline and coldline.
They're designed
for colder data.
They're a little bit
cheaper to store your data.
They cost a little bit
more to access your data.
And in this example up here, the
main thing I wanted to call out
is that for nearline
and coldline,
you can choose either
a regional location
or a multi-regional location.
But they don't really
provide geo diversity
within a single object.
So in this particular
case, object
one is in the left region.
Object two is in
the middle region.
Neither of those
objects are actually
split between multiple regions.
OK.
So here's a table that
shows the relative strengths
and weaknesses of our
various storage classes.
And for data
processing workloads,
I wanted to call
out two attributes,
The first is local latency.
Your data processing
workload, you
want to locate your compute
next to your storage.
And regional has much
tighter local agency balance.
This is actually maybe not
as obvious as it might seem.
The reason why is
for multi-regional,
we have multiple replicas.
And as long as a replica
is near your compute,
you might think the
latency is going to be OK.
Right?
But the reality is that for our
multi-regional storage class,
you define a
overall multi-region
that we store your data in.
Such as a US or Asia or EU.
And you don't have really
fine grained control
over exactly which regions
within the multi region
that are used.
And so even though
we do make an attempt
to keep your data in the region
that you initially wrote it in,
over time it can migrate out.
And that can result in
higher tail latency.
The second reason that
local latency isn't as great
is a little bit more subtle.
And that has to do
with the write latency.
So for the multi-regional
storage class, we of course
replicate your data to
two different locations.
And we need to maintain
some type of metadata
that says where your
data is actually located.
And this metadata has to be
replicated to multiple regions
as well, right?
If we didn't, then we're not
really providing a true fault
tolerance across regions.
So that's one aspect.
The other aspect is that
GCS provides strong read
after write consistency.
So that means if
I write an object,
we guarantee that
every read afterwards
is going to see
this latest version.
So when you look at those
two pieces combined,
what that implies
is that you're going
to have to syncronize this to
replicate your metadata out.
And so every write
is going to result
in at least one remote round
trip out of the region.
And so no matter how
much we optimize,
you're going to be bound
by that network latency.
So local agency
is one big reason
why you want to use regional
for data processing.
The other reason is actually
something pretty cool
that we haven't announced
I think until now.
And that is for the regional
storage class, as well
as any nearline or coldline
that uses a regional location,
we're now guaranteeing strong
list after write consistency.
So this means that if
you write an object
and then you immediately
list your objects,
the newly written object
is going to show up.
We guarantee that.
And if you delete an object
and then list all your objects,
that object was
guaranteed to not show up.
So now all of a
sudden, your workloads
can really rely on this
strong consistency,
which can be really useful.
And we don't yet have
this for multi-regional.
So is a pretty strong reason
to go ahead and use regional.
Next I wanted to
talk a little bit
about some of the performance
characteristics of GCS.
These are really, really
rough rules of thumb.
I essentially tried to make the
first number be powers of 2.
But they're relatively accurate.
And the thing to
notice here is that GCS
is relatively strong in terms
of single stream throughput.
We think we usually
roughly around 800 megabits
per second for reads, 400
megabits per second for writes.
On the flip side,
we're relatively
weak in terms of the fixed
latency cost per request.
And so a rough rule of
thumb is 100 milliseconds
for read, 200
milliseconds for writes.
So there's a couple
of implications here.
So first is obviously favor
larger requests, right?
Take advantage of
that throughput.
Second of all, if you
do have small requests,
parallelize them, right?
So that way, you're really
overlapping that fixed cost,
fixed latency cost.
And then finally,
this is a little bit
subtle, but in general for
data processing workloads,
you want to avoid
resumable uploads.
Especially for small requests.
And the definition of small is
somewhat surprising sometimes.
Does that mean five
megabytes or 10 megabytes?
Maybe 100 megabytes?
Well, if you look at our 400
megabits per second write,
that's equivalent to 50
megabytes per second.
If you have a one
gigabyte size object,
that means that a 1
gigabyte sized object can
be written in about 20 seconds.
So if you're willing to give
up to 20 seconds of work
in the rare case that
you encounter an error,
then you actually don't really
need to be using resumable.
And the reason why we
don't recommend resumable
for these small requests
is that a resumable upload
requires at least two
round trips to the server.
The first round trip
establishes a unique session
that you then use in your second
round trip to upload your data.
And again, because we had
this fixed latency cost,
that's going to
add up over time.
I actually wanted to mention
kind of an interesting story.
We actually ran
into this ourselves
once, where we were doing some
benchmarking using test DFS IO.
What this does is essentially
spins up a bunch of workers,
and it does a bunch of writes
and does a bunch of reads.
So it's a very simple I/O test.
And when we ran
this benchmark, it
was taking a little bit
longer than we expected.
So we dug in.
And the reading and
the writing portion
was actually quite quick.
It was sort of scaling
as we expected.
However, the job was taking
a long time to start up.
So when we dug into that
even further, what we noticed
is that the controller was
writing these small control
files that coordinate
all the workers.
And it was running these small
files serially, one by one.
It was also using
resumable uploads,
so that meant each file
actually required two round
trips to the server.
So if you kind of do
the rough napkin math,
we're talking about 400
milliseconds per control file,
maybe 2.5 control
files per second.
You're talking about
spinning up 1,000 workers,
you're already talking
about 400 seconds
or about six or seven minutes,
just to start up the job.
So in hindsight, it
was pretty obvious.
But it's kind of a
lesson where if you're
taking a workload from
an existing system
and you're moving it to GCS, the
performance characteristics can
be different.
And so you want to
take that into account.
And make sure you're
parallelizing.
OK.
Up next, James is going
to do a quick demo
on Cloud Dataproc that
should hopefully show some
of these principles in play.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Thank you all for being here.
It's nice to see all of you.
So I'm a product manager.
And I focus on Google
Cloud Dataproc.
Dataproc is our managed
Spark and Hadoop offering.
And the demo I'm going to
show you is really important.
Because one of the
principal things that we
try to do with Dataproc
and many of our products
is really separate
storage and compute.
And with Spark and Hadoop,
usually the storage
is intrinsically tied
to your clusters.
So often with Spark
and Hadoop, you
have the Hadoop Distributed
File System, or HDFS.
That often lives
with your cluster.
And a lot of times, you
have to scale your cluster
to store data.
And Hadoop has tried to
solve many of the hard things
that GCS solves behind
the scenes for you.
Like replication, like
performance, durability.
By being able to use
Google Cloud Storage,
you can have your data
live in Google Cloud,
and use it with Dataproc or
any multiple other products,
and you Spark and Hadoop
on that data as you wish.
So the demo I'm going to
show you today is twofold.
One, I'm going to show you a
Spark streaming example that
takes advantage of
the list consistency
that's built into
regional buckets.
What's really cool about that
is soon as we're writing files
to this cloud storage
bucket, Spark Streaming
is picking them up
and processing them.
That's often a very
difficult thing
to do with cloud environments
and block stores.
And the second is, as Mike
said, some of the numbers
we showed you, that's great.
I love showing numbers.
I'm a big fan of
actually showing
you the numbers in real time.
So I wanted to substantiate
some of the performance
that we're seeing, and
talk about how we're really
trying to enhance performance
with Cloud Dataproc and cloud
storage.
So the first thing
I'm going to do here--
and I'll come back to this--
I'm going to submit a job
against two Spark clusters.
These jobs are going to test
a change that we recently
made that I'll talk about
that demonstrates some
of the performance enhancements
and underlying performance
characteristics
of cloud storage.
These are Hadoop jobs.
And behind the
scenes, I'm actually
just running test DFS IO to sort
of link the stories together
here.
And we're going to read 20 files
that are 1000 megabytes apiece.
So I'm going to go ahead and
just kick off these two jobs.
With Cloud Dataproc
we have a control
plain to submit work to
Spark and Hadoop clusters.
You don't have to go in and use
the really complicated Hadoop
tools.
And of course that
just is problematic.
The next thing I'm going
to do is run through a demo
to show you Spark streaming.
And some of the advantages
of using consistency that's
built into regional buckets.
So I have two clusters here.
I'm going to go ahead and
create these clusters.
And these clusters are going
to go and actually read data
from my cloud storage bucket.
And they're in the
process of creating.
And I'll actually
show you, we generally
can create Spark
and Hadoop clusters
in like 60 to 90 seconds.
Which is why I'm totally
comfortable standing up
here and creating Spark
and Hadoop clusters.
In the demo here--
and you can see this
on the very bottom.
And I apologize, it's
a one line shellscript.
But I want to show you
exactly what we're doing.
We're going to copy data
from one bucket to another.
And if it's somewhat not
obvious by the script here,
I've downloaded a bunch of books
from the Rittenberg collection.
So these are text files
that range from like 10
kilobytes to 4 megabytes.
The goal here is
to show you, this
is typical kind of log data.
Like it's going to
be variable size,
it's not going to be huge.
And it takes advantage
of some of the things
that we would recommend if
you're using Spark and Hadoop
with Google Cloud Storage.
Ultimately, I'm going to
copy these files kind of one
at a time, just to show you that
streaming against these files
works.
I'm sleeping for eight
seconds with the cluster,
just so you can
actually see the output.
Unfortunately, Google Cloud
Storage and Cloud Dataproc
are so fast that if
I did it all at once,
you'd just see a
big blur of text.
And it looks cool.
And it looks like your job
is working at warp speed.
But it's really hard to see.
So what we're going to
do is we'll kick off
this Spark streaming job.
And the Spark streaming job--
and if you don't believe
me, the file name
is actually even the same--
this is just a canonical
Spark streaming example.
It's actually from the
Spark documentation.
And it's just reading
data from HDFS.
Or so Spark thinks.
So we have a cloud storage
connector for Spark and Hadoop
that lives on Cloud Dataproc.
And it can read and
write from cloud storage.
And assumes it's HDFS.
And the reason is that we
implement the Hadoop file
system APIs so we can
interact with cloud storage
as if it were HDFS that's
attached to the cluster itself.
So we're going to
run this word count.
And it's just running
against bucket,
which is a regional bucket
that has strong consistency.
These two clusters
that I created,
next demo one and next demo two,
are in two different regions.
And the reason
that I did that was
to show you that we
can actually have
two clusters reading from the
same bucket at the same time.
And this is really powerful.
Because we're actually operating
with two different Spark
and Hadoop clusters against
one cloud storage bucket
at the very same time in two
completely different regions.
The first cluster is
inside of the US region.
And the second is
inside of the EU region.
And we're reading
a data bucket that
is inside of the US region.
So it's actually
really neat to see
that this just kind
of magically works.
So you can see
here, I've already
started streaming files.
And actually this will be a bit
more meaningful here if we go
and go back to our-- let's
look at the jobs here.
So as we're streaming
data to this bucket,
you can see that we're
basically performing
word counts in real time.
And I'm actually getting the
real time output of these files
as they're being written.
If we actually make this Cloud
Shell bigger-- and I apologize,
this is just the unfortunate
side effect of presenting
on a very large screen--
so we're actually just copying
these files over one at a time,
and putting them in that bucket.
As soon as they
appear in that bucket,
they're being instantly
picked up and processed
by Cloud Dataproc.
So when you saw the console,
you saw that we had just
written a file.
Here's the word
count of that file.
And every second Spark
is looking for new files.
And it's doing a word
count on them instantly.
There's not magic here.
It's not complicated.
Literally, all we're
doing is putting
what is a substitute for
log data in a bucket,
and our Spark and Hadoop
clusters are immediately
able to process that data.
If we look at the first
job that I kicked off,
the other thing I want to
share with you is we've
made improvements to our
cloud storage connector
for Spark and Hadoop.
So we read 20 files that
were 1,000 megabytes.
Our average I/O throughput
was 217 megabytes per second.
If we translate that
to megabits per second,
we're looking at well over
1,600 megabits per second.
So 800 may be a great rule.
Your mileage may
vary, of course,
depending on your workloads.
But in general,
this is to show you
that when we say
it's performant,
we're not just saying
it's performant.
It really is performant.
All of these examples will also
be on our GitHub repository,
just in case you want to run
through them and test them.
So as I talked about,
there's a few best practices
that we'd recommend.
If consistency matters,
use regional buckets.
We recommend generally that you
keep your clusters and buckets
close together.
And the reason for
that is if you're
doing things like
stream processing,
milliseconds can matter.
And the closer that
all of your operations
are occurring to each
other, the better.
If you have a lot of
operations, parallelize them.
Because as I showed, you
can read from one bucket
at the same time.
You can have multiple
clusters parallelized,
or you can have
jobs parallelized.
We update Cloud Dataproc and
our cloud storage connector
for Spark and Hadoop frequently.
The SSL improvements that
you saw where we're actually
reading at 1,600
megabits per second
is rolling out in
the next week or two.
If you are using Spark
and Hadoop, 8 cores per VM
will give you the maximum
performance, just based
on our long testing.
And don't use wildcards
in silly ways.
So whenever you do
a wildcard, you're
going to get a list
of the entire bucket.
Don't try and list
a large bucket
if you only need to operate
on a subset of the files.
Because you're going to get
back way more data than you
actually need to operate.
And with that, I will
turn it back over.
Thanks.
MICHAEL YU: Thanks, James.
OK.
Let's move on to
content serving.
So this is any
use case where you
have contents where
in GCS, you want
to distribute it to users
who are potentially all
over the globe.
I showed a slide previously.
The one thing I
wanted to call out
is multi-regional
can be a good source
class to use in this case.
The primary reason
is that you get
better remote latency due
to having multiple replicas.
And of course you get
better availability
due to having geo diversity.
And here, things
like list consistency
don't typically matter as much.
So one of the
things that I think
not everyone knows about us is
that we have this pretty nice
global network.
We do edge caching,
we do core caching.
And so what does
that actually mean?
So without any of
this, typically
what would happen
when a user fetches
a object is the
request would traverse
across the public internet.
And it would eventually
hit the region
that the object's located in.
It would ingress at the
Google network at that region.
We would serve the object and
the response would flow back
over the public internet.
So what GCS actually does is
Google has points of presence
all over the globe.
And we try to get the users'
requests onto our nearest
point of presence.
And once it's on that
point of presence,
we terminate the request,
and we forward it internally
over our private network.
And so a longer
portion of the request
is over a private
network where we
have tighter control over
the quality of service
we can provide.
So that's a pretty nice benefit.
We also end up doing
automatic failover.
So we'll find the
nearest replica.
In this particular
case, it's in region A.
And if region A isn't healthy,
we'll fall back to region B
automatically.
The third thing
that's nice about this
is we have, like I
mentioned earlier,
edge caching, and caching in
our core data centers as well.
So for hot content,
subsequent requests
can be served
directly from cache
rather than having
to travel, say,
halfway around the world
to the original source.
Some of you guys might be
familiar with our Cloud CDN
product and might
be saying, hey,
this sounds really
familiar or very similar.
And that's exactly right.
We actually use the same global
network and the same edge
caching infrastructure
as Cloud CDN.
So really, a lot of
Cloud CDN functionality
is built straight
into GCS without you
having to do anything.
There are also some good
reasons for using Cloud CDN.
In particular, if you want to
set up SSL for custom domains.
Or you want to customize
your URL structure.
Perhaps point a subset of URLs
at GCS, and a subset of URLs
at your compute
instances, you would
want to use Cloud CDN or
a Cloud Load Balancer.
It also provides
differentiated pricing.
So some requests are
served out of cache.
Some requests are served
from cache misses.
And if you want
different pricing there,
you can use cloud CDN.
So next, I'm going to do a quick
demo to sort of demonstrate
what I mean by this
global network.
So over here, you can see
I've created a demo bucket.
You can see it's
multi-regional storage class.
And it's located in the EU.
So it's a pretty good
distance away from here
in San Francisco.
I'm going to switch over
to the terminal here.
And the first thing
I'll do is I'll
ping our bucket right here.
So io321
demo.storage.googleapis.com.
And what you can see
here is that we're
getting a round trip time
of about three milliseconds.
So clearly, it's not
going to Europe, right?
That's maybe 150, 200
milliseconds away.
So the request is getting
terminated somewhere close.
Let's actually go ahead
and perform a trace route.
And what a trace rout
does, is it shows you
all the hops that
a request takes
towards its final destination.
And so you can ignore the
first 11 or so entries here.
The important one here
is this very last entry.
Nuq, something,
something, 1e100.net.
So what is that?
First of all, I'm sure a lot
of you guys already know this.
But Google itself was
actually misnamed.
It was supposed
to be G-O-O-G-O-L.
So if we look up the
definition of that,
it's 1 times 10 to the 100.
And that's exactly
what 1e100 is.
It's our little clever
way of saying, hey,
this is a Google device.
If you look at the
rest of the name--
and we're not going to go
into too many of the details--
you can see nuq.
And you might
wonder what that is.
So if we do a quick
search for that,
it looks like it's
Moffett Federal Airfield,
here in the Bay Area.
So you might guess that request
is getting terminated somewhere
close by here.
We have a point
of presence here.
And that's where we're
handling the request.
And once it gets here, we're
going to go on to Europe.
Right?
OK, so next, I've uploaded
an object into this bucket.
And we can perform a
curl to pull the object.
And we can time it to
see how long it'll take.
So here you can see I'm curling,
I'm just silencing the output.
I'm riding the
output to dev null.
And I'm pulling
this foo.bin object.
All right.
Let's see what happens.
So you can see, it's taking
about 200 milliseconds.
And that makes sense.
It's got to traverse
all the way to Europe
to get this thing, right?
So how do we actually
enable this edge caching?
What we can do is if you go
into your storage browser,
we can edit the data
properties of the object.
Here you can see that one
of the metadata properties
is cache control header.
And it's being set to private.
So if we wipe this
out, by default GCS
will mark your object
as publicly cacheable,
assuming your object
is actually public.
If it's private, it
won't do this, of course.
So I'm going to just go
ahead and clear this out.
OK.
So now if I go back and
rerun that curl command
to pull the object, previously
it was about 200 milliseconds.
We're now seeing about
20-ish milliseconds,
20 to 30 milliseconds.
So that goes to show that the
object's now cached closer
to the edge.
And it's being served
straight from that.
So it's a pretty
simple technique.
Obviously just enable caching.
But it's one of
the things that I
think is not always well
known, is that we have this CDN
functionality built in.
And if you pair it with the
multi-regional storage class,
you're talking
about geo diversity,
CDN-like functionality,
all sort of in one product
without having to do too
much additional set up.
That said, we still
definitely recommend
using independent CDNs.
There's nice benefits to that.
They have different
reaches than Google has.
So besides having
that additional reach,
it's nice having that
additional redundancy.
And it also allows caching
of private content.
So if you use a CDN, one
of the things we recommend
is a seven origin shield.
What that does is normally
when you have a cache miss,
all of your edge nodes are going
to fetch the data so that they
can fill their cache, right?
An origin shield is
an intermediate cache.
Where your edge nodes can
talk to the origin shield,
the origin shield
can fetch your data,
and then it can serve that data
back out to your edge nodes.
And this is really
nice especially
if using coldline or nearline,
where the access charges
are a little bit higher.
That origin shield allows
all of your edge nodes
to cache fill with
a single request.
The other thing is if you
do use an origin shield,
I recommend the
multi-regional storage class.
The regional storage
class is actually
sometimes useful as well.
Because you can place your
origin shield and your bucket
very, very close together.
And that'll give you a
little tighter control
over your latency when
there is a cache miss.
It's a little tighter
control of your tail agency.
OK.
Third section is going
to be on write scaling.
So this is a common
pattern that we see.
We see folks who
are writing objects.
And maybe they're naming the
objects after the current time.
And they're writing
them in order.
So in this particular case, I
have a whole bunch of jpegs.
And maybe there's been
time stamped by my camera.
And often what we see
is when this happens,
people are able to scale
the write rate for a while.
And then all of a sudden,
they hit this wall.
And they can't seem to get over
a certain writes per second.
So what's going on here?
To kind of understand, we
should actually take a step back
and see how GCS was designed.
And we start off with
a few requirements.
Back in the day, we wanted to
be able to read and write data,
and perhaps do that quickly.
And you know,
that's not too bad.
And then you might add
another requirement.
Which is hey, you
should probably
be resilient to power
failure or hardware
failure or human failure.
So things are getting
a little bit harder.
But still kind of all in all,
I think we can deal with this.
We can use journaling to recover
from power failure, replication
to handle hardware
failure, and all sorts
of different techniques
for human failure backup.
Slow rollouts, automation
testing, that sort of thing.
So we can take care
of this as well.
And then maybe a
third requirement
was hey we should probably
scale to lots of data.
And still at this
point, it's not too bad.
We can use essentially
a distributed hash.
And this scales pretty well.
We distribute our objects pretty
evenly across all of our nodes.
We can still do things
relatively quickly.
You hash your
object, you quickly
find which node owns it, and
you go directly to that node.
There's not a lot of
intermediate layers
there to cause scaling
bottlenecks or performance
bottlenecks.
And I kind of underplayed
this because actually there's
a lot of smart folks
who have done this
and we're lucky to be
able to rely on it.
But this was actually how one
of the initial versions of GCS
was built internally.
We were essentially this
big distributed hash.
So unfortunately, folks
came along and said, hey,
I'd be really nice if
we could list our data.
And we want to be able to
list our data in order.
We want it to be accurate.
Which means we talked about
strong list consistency.
That's been one of the large
requests that we've had.
And we want to be able
to do that quickly.
And so it's this
last requirement
that really is problematic.
The distributed hash approach
really doesn't work now.
There's no affinity
between objects
that have similar names.
And so in order for
you to list in order,
you essentially have to
query every single note.
If a single node fails,
your entire listing fails.
If a single node is slow,
your entire listing is slow.
Right?
So this essentially
forces us to do sharding
a little bit differently.
Where we shard objects into
lexicographical ranges.
So in this example,
I've got nine ranges.
The first shard is any object
whose name comes before 05.jpg.
And the second shard is any
object whose name comes between
05.jpg and 22.jpg.
And what GCS does is
it takes the shards
and it distributes
them to machines.
And here's an example,
we have four machines
and we distribute the shards.
We, of course, have replication.
So you can imagine
having different zones
with replicas of these shards.
And we don't necessarily
have to distribute
the shards the same way.
But the key thing here is in
order for this to be effective,
the amount of load that
shards 1, 2, and 3 receive
has to be roughly equal
to the amount of load
that 4 and 5 receive.
And 6 and 7, and 8 and 9.
Right?
If we don't, then each of
these four machines in that
left region, they're not going
to have even load balancing.
So the problem is
how do we decide
what these lexicographical
ranges should be.
So that we get this nice
even load balancing.
It's actually a little bit hard.
Primarily because
we don't really
control what the
object naming is.
And we don't really
control the access pattern
that our users use when
they access their objects.
So here's one example
of a potential load
versus object names.
And here's another very
different example, right?
In that second
example, this could
be someone who's writing to two
subdirectories, foo and bar.
And not writing anything
else outside of that.
And so only around
foo and around bar
do you see these spikes in load.
And so for that, we would
of course split the ranges
within foo and bar.
And for this other one, we
would have probably much more
even splits.
So one of the key things
here that I want to point out
is we need a little bit help.
We have to really look
at your past behavior
to try to figure out
how to shard things.
And we will do that, right?
If you maintain a
relatively consistent load,
we'll figure it out.
We'll split things into
the appropriate shards
and redistribute.
But if you're constantly
moving around,
then it makes it very
hard for us to react.
Let's go back to in-order
writes for a second
and see why these
are problematic.
So if we start out, let's
imagine we're writing 00.jpg
through 99.jpg in order.
And we'll start
off with the base
where we have just
a single shard.
That means only a single machine
can handle these requests.
So we're writing these in
order for machine number one.
And of course, if we wanted
to use a second machine,
that's not going
be doing anything.
There's not a shard that we
can assign to that machine.
And so with this current set
up, the amount of write scaling
you can get is
going to be limited
by the capacity of
a single machine.
So one of the things we
might think to do is let's
split up our shards.
Let's have two shards.
0 through 50, 50 through 99.
And let's distribute
each of these shards
to a different machine.
So what happens with
in-order writes?
First of all, you start writing
00, 01, all the way through 49.
All of those hit
that first shard.
All of those end up
on machine number one.
And while machine
number one is handling
all these writes, machine.
Number two is
sitting there idle.
Not doing anything at all.
Right?
And then you start writing
50.jpg, 51.jpg through 99.jpg.
And these all of us are
hitting the second shard,
which is hosted on
machine number two.
And since all the requests are
going to machine number two,
machine number one is idle.
So at any given point in time,
only one machine is active.
And your total write capacity is
limited by that single machine.
So this particular
strategy hasn't really
bought us anything in terms of
our ability to scale writes.
We could take this
to the extreme
and use a ton of shards.
In this example, we have
a bunch of shards, one
essentially for
every single object.
And if we distribute
those shards alternatingly
between machine one
and two, we can indeed
use both machine one
and two simultaneously.
And then we've doubled our
write throughput, right?
But this isn't really practical.
It doesn't scale well.
There's a lot of overhead in
terms of maintaining shards.
And so that's one issue.
And the other issue
is that we still
have to be able to predict
the fact that you're
writing sequentially.
And do this type of
splitting ahead of time.
We can't react after the fact.
We have to know up front
that this is happening.
So this is still
fairly problematic.
The solution here
is really to try
to change your write pattern.
So for example,
rather than writing 0
through 99, just
sequentially, you
could go ahead and write
from two workers in parallel.
0 to 49, 50 through 99.
And if you do that, then this
previous split into two shards
is actually pretty effective.
You end up hitting both machines
one and two at the same time,
you've essentially double
your write throughput.
And if you do this,
by the way, GCS
will figure out that these
are the right ranges that
should be used for the shards.
It just takes a
little bit of time.
So to recap, some of the best
practices for write scaling
is for your steady
state load, make
sure you're pointing your
load at a consistent range
of objects.
If you're writing into,
say, a foo subdirectory,
keep it in the foo subdirectory.
Over time, GCS is going to
figure out your write pattern.
It's going to split,
it's going to scale.
If you suddenly shift over
to a different prefix,
we will again, you know,
react and split and scale.
But it will take some time.
And you might see a little
bit of a blip in terms
of your write throughput.
If you're doing a one
off write where maybe you
don't have control
over the names
of your objects, parallelize.
Right?
Parallelize over
different ranges.
This particular problem
doesn't affect everybody.
Roughly, you can expect
to be able to get
a low thousands of
writes per second
before you end up with any
write scaling bottlenecks.
And we're working
pretty hard right now
to actually raise
that quite a bit.
But just as a rough
rule of thumb,
if you expect to need to
go over a few thousand
writes per second,
start planning
for changing your
write access pattern
to avoid these bottlenecks.
And then finally in terms
of how quickly GCS reacts,
you want to think on the order
of low number of minutes.
So again, it takes some time
to learn, some time to react.
So it's not maybe as
quick as we'd like.
To get a little
bit more concrete
in terms of what
you can do here,
I already mentioned
the idea that you
can upload from multiple
directories in parallel.
That's one way to really access
multiple object ranges at once.
Another thing you
can do is let's
say you're writing a bunch
of objects sequentially.
So in this case, 0005123.jpg.
You can actually hash
that name and insert
the prefix of the hash.
And by doing that, since your
hash function is creating
hash values that should
be uniform over the range
of hash values, you're
distributing your load.
And you're allowing GCS
to go ahead and create
splits that are effective.
And you don't necessarily
have to put this hash
at the very beginning
of your object name.
So in this example,
we inserted the hash
after the foo directory.
And that means that any rights
that go into the foo directory
are going to be split.
And they're going to
scale really, really well.
And so that'll work just fine.
Again, as long as
you don't suddenly
shift your traffic from foo to
a different prefix like bar.
OK.
So that's write scaling.
To wrap this up, I wanted
to talk about retries a bit.
So here is a typical
retry strategy.
It should look pretty familiar.
You get an error.
You do exponential back
off, you add jitter.
Things are great.
So one question that
kind of comes up
is what's an appropriate
timeout when I call GCS.
You might see something
on the short end
like 500 milliseconds.
You might see something
on the long end, something
like 10 seconds.
So what's a good timeout?
It's tough because there's
a little bit of a trade off.
If you use a short timeout,
then what's really nice
is that if you happen to hit
a unlucky slow machine that's
maybe temporarily overloaded,
you retry quickly.
And so you control your
tail latency pretty well.
However, if system wide,
we're seeing a slow down,
then you might be
prematurely giving up.
Maybe if you had waited just
a second or two seconds,
your request would complete.
And now all of a sudden,
all of your requests
are failing because you've
set this really short 500
millisecond timeout.
It also ends up wasting a bunch
of work on the server's side.
On the flip side, if you
set a really long timeout,
then you're resilient to
the system wide slowdowns.
But you're now susceptible
to tail latency.
Again, if I hit that
unlucky machine,
I'm waiting around potentially
for 10 seconds before I retry.
And if I'd simply
retried faster,
I could have got back to
the user a lot quicker.
Right?
And one of the things I
actually want to mention
is that tail latency is
sometimes a bigger problem
than you might imagine.
So for example, let's say
we're measuring tail latency
at 99th percentile.
So one out of every 100 requests
is taking, say, one second.
And for any given user
visible operation,
you might be doing a whole
bunch of lower level operations.
So in this particular
case, let's assume
you're making 50
parallel reads to GCS.
And you need to
wait for all of them
to complete before you
consider your job done.
And by the way, again,
this doesn't necessarily
have to be GCS.
You can imagine
loading a web page,
you're loading multiple assets.
Basically, there's a
lot of sub operations
that really have to
complete before you're done.
Well unfortunately, if
there is a 99% chance
that any particular request
succeeds in one second,
then there's 0.99 raised to
the 50th chance that all 50
of those requests are going
to succeed within one second.
And that's surprisingly low.
It's less than 61%.
So all of a sudden,
you're talking
about a property that
really only affects one out
of 100 requests.
It's causing over a third
of your jobs to be slow.
Right?
So it can be surprising.
Like tail latency can have a
bigger impact on median latency
and on your overall
latency once you step up.
So one of the strategies you can
use for addressing tail latency
is something called
hedge requests.
So the idea here is let's
say we start an attempt,
we make an RPC.
And it's taking a while--
it hasn't come back yet.
We can designate
some type of timeout.
And I'll go into more detail
like what a good timeout is.
But for now, let's
suppose we wait
until are expected 95th
percentile latency.
And we still haven't
gotten a response yet.
At this point, you can actually
submit a second attempt.
You don't cancel
the first attempt,
you don't mark it as failed, you
just submit the second attempt.
And because we've chosen 95th
percentile latency as our cut
off, in theory this
should only generate
about 5% extra traffic.
So it's manageable.
Right?
Now, if this were a
case where we simply
were hitting an unlucky
machine, an unhealthy machine,
and that's it, it's not a system
wide issue, then this retry,
chances are it's going
to hit a healthy machine.
And it's going to
complete pretty quickly.
Because typically, your
median or your common latency
is much, much shorter
than your tail latency.
So if that's the
case, then attempt
number two is going to succeed.
You can cancel
attempt number one.
You can go ahead and
return the result
from your second attempt.
Right?
What happens if we were in
system wide overload though?
Well, the nice thing with this
approach is that you never
actually cancelled
attempt number one.
You don't use an
artificially low timeout.
Right?
You kept, say, a reasonable
five or 10 second timeout.
And so if the overall
system is slow
and maybe all requests are
taking about two seconds,
you can still wait for attempt
number one to complete.
Or attempt number two.
But in this particular case,
since attempt number one
was started earlier, chances are
that it will complete sooner.
So once attempt
number one succeeds,
you again cancel
attempt number two.
And you go ahead and return the
result from attempt number one.
So this is a head
retry strategy.
It's really nice-- in
this particular case,
we use the 95th
percentile as the cutoff.
You could expect that to impact
your tail latency at a longer
tail.
Right
So a couple of
notes around this.
I mentioned that if we chose
a 95th percentile cut off,
we would generate about
5% extra retry traffic.
That's not always true.
95th percentile latency
can change over time.
Right?
So temporarily what you think
is 95th percentile latency--
maybe the entire
system gets slow,
and now you're retrying
every single request.
So it's safer to put a hard
cap in terms of how many hedged
requests you perform.
Maybe limit x percent
of your overall traffic.
Say 5% or 10%.
And that way, when you're going
through these transitions,
you're not going to
generate a retry storm.
The other general recommendation
is in order to retry,
you really need to
have idempotence.
Right?
And this means that I
can perform an operation
multiple times.
And the end result is
going to be the same.
And there's a couple of cases
where this is not obvious.
Where a particular request
might be idempotent,
but a sequence of
requests isn't.
So for example, let's suppose
I write A to an object.
And then I follow it up and
I overwrite that with B. OK?
Now let's suppose that first
attempt when I wrote A,
it was being a little bit slow.
So I made an attempt,
I tried to write A,
it's taken a long time,
so I go ahead and I retry.
And that second
attempt succeeds.
So now we've written A.
I move on and I write B.
And unfortunately, that first
attempt to write A finishes up.
What does it do?
It overwrites B.
And the net result
is I'm left with A. Right
And that's unexpected.
You would expect that slow
request to be dead and not
have any effect.
But it's actually
living in the system
somewhere and kind of
coming back to bite you.
So there's a couple of
ways to work around this.
One obvious way is simply
don't overwrite objects.
Anytime you write new content,
choose a different name.
If you do this, you're
not going to ever run
into this type of issue.
You can also use preconditions.
For example, if I had
said write A if and only
if the object didn't
exist previously.
And then I can say it right
B only if the contents
of the object-- or the
version of the object was A.
If you do this, then that
initial request to A is not
going to overwrite
B. Because B's--
the object exists at that point.
Right?
And then lastly, I just wanted
to point out exponential
back off with jitter, like
the standard retry strategy.
You should still be doing it.
And really think
of it as focusing
on when you get an error.
If I get an immediate 503 or 429
service telling me to back off
or that it's
unhealthy, of course
you continue to do exponential
back off with jitter.
This hedge retry strategy,
in some ways it's orthogonal.
It allows you to address
your tail latency.
OK.
So that's everything
we had today.
Just to quickly recap, we
covered four different areas--
data processing,
content serving,
write scaling, and retries.
And be careful with the storage
classes that you choose.
Make sure you're
favoring larger requests,
and you're parallelizing
as much as possible.
Make sure you're
turning on caching
so you can take advantage of
our built-in CDN functionality.
And then make sure
your write pattern
isn't going to generate
unexpected bottlenecks later
on.
And then finally, think about
using a hedge requests to cut
down on your tail latency.
So all right.
Thank you, everyone.